les marchés ont chuté dès la mi février
alors qu'il devenait clair qu'on s'en
allait dans le mur avec la coved 19 et
qu'il allait être obligatoire finalement
de stopper l'économie rappelez-vous mais
depuis le 23 mars les marchés sont en
reprise
pourquoi simon plantes et gestionnaire
de portefeuille à la financière banque
nationale bonsoir simon plantes
bonsoir on a clairement une tendance à
la hausse en une reprise là depuis 7
semaines maintenant malgré les mauvaises
nouvelles malgré la persistance quand
même de la pandémie pas clair qu'on va
s'en sortir et commun la comment ça
s'explique cette reprise boursière
je pense qu est-ce qui sous presse on
prend plus ses investisseurs des fonds
d'une perception de 10 à la bourse va
vraiment bougé en tandem avec l'économie
puis évidemment votre l'économie dans
les prochains mois ça va vraiment et à
des films et pendant cette période là on
voit les sociétés grimper si on regarde
plus précisément on promettent les
sociétés dans différents secteurs je
pensais en arrêt 3 2 les sociétés qui
vont gagner qui vont tirer profit cet
environnement là ce ne peut occulter la
catalyse de cette croissance là et des
sociétés qui sont un peu sur le banc de
punition si je pourrais dire mais c'est
temporaire
finalement ils vraiment les secteurs qui
sont plus à risque alors détaillé fekter
là les lits trois-là dont vous me parlez
mais si on regarde par exemple certains
indices boursiers je donne par exemple
existent du nasdaq
40% du nasdaq en fait et qu'on sent prêt
à peu près dans cinq sociétés microsoft
amazon apple puis le secteur vraiment
des technologies des communications
ce jeune chien exemple de microsoft avec
ce qui se passe actuelle actuellement
les grandes entreprises elles veulent
assurer une connectivité collaboration à
distance au niveau de leurs employés
dont des outils que microsoft peut
déployer bien évidemment pour eux sont
nettement bien avantagé
et donc on va présenter un graphique où
on voit justement les trois indices
américains les trois principaux le
construit le s p 500 le down jones et le
nasdaq
et on voit que le nasdaq après la chute
a repris essentiellement parce que
toutes ses pertes
ou du moins est revenu en territoire
positif pour l'année 2020 ce qui n'est
pas le cas du s&p 500 et du dow jones
encore pour l'instant
un nom c'est exact son regard des
sociétés comme amazon qui ont eu un gain
d'environ 30% depuis le début de l'année
il se distingue nettement mais c est ce
qu on doit ça en état est ce qu'on doit
s'étonner de cela de cette reprise parce
que je reviens dans les dates là au mois
de mars
on a commencé à fermer tranquillement à
la mi mars puis on a vraiment fermé
autour du 23 mars
or c'est à ce moment là que la reprise
s'est amorcée aidez nous à comprendre
pourquoi les marchés boursiers voit les
choses autrement
il ya toujours un décalage avec les
nouvelles quotidiennes ouest sud il faut
être quand même parce que c'est vrai si
on regarde en ce moment la bourse
'l'indice le principal que je recommande
sur le s p 500 aux états unis 500 plus
grandes sociétés américaines mais a
laissé au même niveau à peu près qui
était au mois d'août mois de septembre
dernier puis à l'époque son fils une
projection des 12 24 prochains mois deux
points de vue économique c'est sûr qu'on
n'imaginait pas la réalité auxquels vont
faire face actuelle marquée c'est normal
de se poser des questions par conte
comme je disais tout à l'heure
la bourse n'est pas nécessairement
synonyme avis économies lorsque des
vestiaires va investir en bourse
investissant société va en théorie de
faire une projection par exemple sur 5
ans 10 ans donc mon entreprise c'est
quoi son avantage compétitif ça va être
quoi ses revenus dans les dix prochaines
années
évidemment cette projection les deux
premières années
ben avec ce qu'on va vivre ça va être
difficile mais c'est vrai ce que
éventuellement dans trois ans quatre ans
on va voir certain retour à la normale
donc pour ce que lorsqu'on fait une
projection pour l'actualiser aujourd'hui
ben on peut dire que qui est quand même
du positif à traverser pour certains
secteurs en particulier c'est pour ça
qu'on veut c'est tout le moins baissé et
la bourse
c'est un art où on loge notre capitale
puis l'autre point je vais amener à
travers cette crise love paris du 23
mars mais par la suite perdant on a vu
les taux d'intérêts vraiment baisser
encore plus on était déjà dans un
environnement de faibles taux puis
maintenant on a des taux d'intérêt en
bas de 1% en amérique du nord
donc on n'est plus dans une situation de
y a pas d'alternative donc sont étonnés
reste à connaître
j'ai ctions sur cinq ans ou dix ans nous
dit ouais en bourse la marche est assez
cher par contre mon rendement votre
probable plus élevé qu est ce que je
peux le faire en restant liquidités ou
en investissant dans des super des
titres ou plus sécuritaire offre un taux
d'intérêt en bas de l'inflation faible
taux qui s'accompagne d'injection
massive des banques centrales et des
gouvernements dans l'économie oui
effectivement c'est sûr que ça ça va
amener on voit vraiment des
investissements puis sur un autre point
je pense que on connaît pas la meilleure
quai de la bourse
oui c'est effectivement pas avoir à se
refaire accule mais entre le 23 mars
qu'aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on
a vu vraiment des interventions tirait
la très rapide très drastiques au niveau
des banques centrales à travers le monde
au niveau des gouvernements pour
supporter l'économie puis maintenant le
rebond qu'on voit aussi dans la bourse
probablement ça va donner du courage des
investisseurs vis à vis ainsi un autre
recul probablement aussi jouer
participer
ouais est ce que les investisseurs sont
inquiets selon vous l'êtes vous vous en
tout cas d'une possible deuxième vague
de contagion ont fait face à l'inconnu
comprendre ce que veut on n'a jamais
vécu selon nos stratégies les restes
humains faut ce qu'il faut se préparer
pour tout les scénarios je suis moins
spécialistes de ce côté le point de vue
sanitaire mais oui effectivement ce
serait très probable d'avoir une seconde
vague et donc il ya un nouveau une
nouvelle chute boursière
mais comme je mentionnais le marché
votre placement aller exactement parce
que le marché va évaluer l'avenir puis
une chose qui est un peu plus certains
dans cet environnement le 6 on se
projette exemple dans deux ans plusieurs
spécialistes disent que d'ici deux ans à
avoir non seulement des traitements ou
s'il va être un pack 5
donc on peut voir on peut etre transmis
sont une raison qui beaucoup plus à long
terme
merci beaucoup simon plainte pour cette
analyse ce soir merci